[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
so
welcome to the 2022 singfield cup in st
louis missouri
please welcome your host for this
evening grand master alejandro ramirez
[Music]
welcome everyone
to a great day for chess i'm very
excited to be here it's not so often
that we celebrate more than one event
here at the st louis chess club but
today
it's just such a great day we're
celebrating the 50th
anniversary of the victory of bobby
fischer over boris paskey in the world
championship match of 1972 which
happened exactly 50 years ago so give it
up for the old man bobby fisher
[Applause]
of course it is great for me to see how
chess has exploded in st louis and thank
you everyone that participated in our
simul a 50 board simul to celebrate of
course the 50 years since the match but
that's not the only reason that we are
here we are also here at the
inauguration of one of the by now
traditional events in american soil of
course we are talking about the
strongest tournament held in america
every year the sink field cup
this year the sink field cup also serves
as the last stop of the grand chess tour
and everything is to be played for i
love when the granchester comes to st
louis and it's still very very very
exciting
thank you everybody that made this event
possible
especially thank you to the people and
the visionaries behind all of these
projects
first and foremost dr ginny singhfield
and rexingfield who without we would
just not be able to have any of the
celebrations or any chess in st louis to
the level that we're able to have these
days so an applause for them please
[Applause]
and a big thank you to everybody that
makes the grand chess tour function like
a well-oiled machine of course i have to
thank the visionary behind the tour uh
not present with us today but he will be
later gary kasparov who was
everything behind this tour and the
reason that we're celebrating the end of
it here today
[Applause]
special thank you to michael korkowski
the executive director of the grand
chess tour to teresa privanova that
makes everything run and of course here
in st louis tony rich and joy bray who
without them
nothing in single is chess wise whatever
works so big round of applause for them
and of course the grand chess tour
involves more than one continent and i
would like to thank our partners over in
europe that uh a super bad foundation
for their support in the grand chester
for bucharest warsaw and croatia
[Applause]
i would like to introduce leslie
hoffworth the president and executive
director here at forest park forever
leslie has served as a president
executive director since 2010 and has
been the leading has been leading
organization through strategic growth
and a transition of its mission by
partnering here with the city of st
louis so without any further ado
leslie hoffworth
[Applause]
good evening and welcome to forest park
we are so happy to have you here and i'm
just so honored that this event is being
held in forest park this is the the
heart of st louis and i cannot think of
a better partnership
for us to have than with
the sink fields and the chess center
chess in forest park they go together
and you can play chess in forest park on
the east side of the park by the way but
i want to welcome you here um forest
park forever for those who don't know
we're a non-profit conservancy we work
in partnership as was mentioned with the
city of st louis to take care of forest
park today and to make sure it's in
great shape forever and that it has the
things that people are really wanting to
make the most of their visit here so
again we're so excited to have this
event to kick it off here in forest park
and we hope you enjoy your evening thank
you
[Applause]
and here to introduce a man that wears
many caps in the chess world he's the
executive director of the st louis chess
club but he's also an international
arbiter a good friend and somebody that
takes care of all the my new details of
the club tony rich
[Music]
thank you very much alejandro and thank
you all again for joining us this
evening you know i remember the early
days of the sing field cup the very
first event that we held was just four
players
you know it was lavon aronian it was
magnus carlson gotta kamsky and hikaru
nakamura we've grown the singfield cup
from a four-player event featuring some
of the very best players in the u.s and
in the world
to a cornerstone of american chess every
year being the strongest chess
tournament held on american soil and i
have to say that i'm very proud to be a
part of that tradition
there are a few folks here that i'd like
to recognize as well uh if you would
stan when i call your name i want to
make sure that everybody gets a chance
to know who you are as well
uh one of the reasons that the chess
club has been so successful is because
of our partnership with us chess
us chess is the governing body of chess
in america and they sanction events like
the us championships that we host here
in st louis in fact coming up in october
i'd like to recognize the president of
u.s chess who's here with us this
evening randy bauer
[Applause]
and the executive director at u.s chess
carol meyer
[Applause]
[Music]
with the u.s chess trust mr al lawrence
and with chess.com danny wrench is here
somewhere too
[Applause]
thanks hayley
[Applause]
you know it's funny this is the 50-year
celebration of bobby fischer's victory
over boris baskey in 1972.
something else happened in 1972 and that
was that bob jacobs
won or tied for first in the 1972 golden
knights correspondents chess
championship now who in the heck is bob
jacobs bob jacobs is probably apart from
rex and genie uh the next person who
should be thanked for the existence of
the saint louis chess club bob was our
founding president of the board of
directors in 2008 and in fact i think it
was about this time
uh 15 years ago yeah
15 years ago that bob gave me a call and
said hey i know this guy rex he just
retired moved back to the st louis area
and he wants to to start a chess club
you want to get together for a dinner
and talk to him about maybe how he could
start a little chess club
and
yeah 15 years later it's not such a
little chess club anymore rex you and
genie have done so much to make chess
and st louis synonymous
you've done so much to enrich my life
and the life of every chess player
not just in this country but really
around the world and thanks are due to
both of you for all of those efforts
thank you both very much
[Applause]
uh next up so the singfield cup
i'm an organizer for this event but in
my heart i'm an arbiter so i wear that
judge hat with pride i'm really happy
that we've got such an amazing uh
arbiting team here uh you know for the
saint louis rapid and blades we had aris
margaret and uh karen penick who joined
us
as well as the chief arbiter for that
event chris byrd chris was also joining
us as the chief arbiter for the sink
field cup in addition to that other hat
that he wears as the deputy tour arbiter
of the grand chess tour
and he's joined by enrique huerta as our
other arbiter so thank you both ahead of
time for any headaches that you may face
in the tournament
[Applause]
uh from a technical perspective i'll
keep it short and sweet the singfield
cup is a 10 player tournament
reigning world champion magnus carlson
is playing as is the defending uh victor
of the singfield cup the 2021 champion
maxine vasciola grave is back to defend
his title in addition to that we have
eight other world-class players who each
want their shot at winning one of the
grand chess tour events taking the first
place prize money and their share of the
three hundred and fifty thousand dollars
so make sure you tune in to
grandchester.org each day you can watch
all of the wonderful commentary that we
have there and see who will ultimately
become the sink field cup champion
without further ado it is my pleasure to
introduce to you my partner in crime
the chief curator at the world chess
hall of fame shannon bailey
[Applause]
oh
i'm so sorry i have a typo uh it is my
pleasure to introduce to you
the co-founder of the st louis chess
club dr jeannie singfield
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome to st louis chess
hey i would like all the people who
played against our top 10 players to
just stand up because they made this a
wonderful event if you played stand up
and then they're the wonderful grand
masters who played i hope none of you
lost
but could you just stand up so we can
see the best players
okay
[Applause]
now the first group i had stand up i'm
hoping some of you
in maybe
10 or 15 years
will be playing up here because chess
comes out of saint louis so
so my job is always to
introduce
my loving husband the godfather of
american chess and
i want you to know that he played
tonight
although he didn't win i i
he didn't lose on scholars mate so
congratulations rex
[Applause]
welcome everyone thank you genie for
highlighting my terrible performance
this is always a
favorite time of the year when the best
chess players in the world gather in st
louis
uh it is just incomparable
um
leslie holforth i would like to thank
you in forest park forever for hosting
tonight's event what a beautiful
backdrop to a 50 person simul
and i'm biased but i believe this is one
of the most beautiful and one of the
largest parks in the united states
and also i want to
[Applause]
i want to recognize two people that are
here that you should all know about the
fire chief of st louis chief jenkerson
and mike kraus the fire chief of metro
wells west
where they are right there
[Applause]
and thanks also to tony ritz the
executive director of the chess club
shannon bailey the curator of the world
chess hall of fame
and joy bray who makes everything run
flawlessly
at the hall of fame and the chess club
thank you all for the wonderful job you
do
and i also want to thank all the
contractors the vendors randy and his
team
spectrum and kevin and his crew at
silverback and all those who make the
broadcast and live show such an amazing
event
and of course now it's a pleasure to
recognize
the three greatest sports broadcasters
in the world our chess commentators
grand master yasser cerewon
grand master peter svidler
[Applause]
and grandmaster alejandro ramirez
[Applause]
now i have to admit that many of you
know that bobby fischer is one of my
heroes and i think it's great that we're
celebrating his victory
on this incredible opening night and i
don't think
if he hadn't done that we would all be
here today
lastly i would encourage all of you to
go to the exhibit the fishers basket
exhibit at the world chess hall of fame
it is just incredible
joy and i thought this was kind of a
low-key secret event up until four or
five weeks ago when out of the blue she
gets a phone call from france a fellow
introduces himself as boris spassky jr
so
and we sent three people over he said my
father has lots of memorabilia that we
want to share with your exhibit so
that's a wonderful thing thank you joy
[Applause]
thank you all ladies and gentlemen and
now i'm ready to turn it back over to
our moderator
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you rex uh personal note and as
rex said many of us wouldn't be here
without that great victory of bobby
fischer over boris paske and i have to
say
i am one of those that benefited from
the fisher boom my dad learned chess
because bobby fisher won that match and
that's how i got to learn chess and
that's how my entire life changed i
ended up in saint louis
the sinful cup holds a special place in
my heart
i've attended every single sinkhole cup
since its inception in 2013
and i've had the pleasure of
working for the event
in one capacity or another
i'm happy to be a commentator in this
time but
it brings me true joy to see these
players the best of the best
exhibit their chess here in st louis
so
i would first like to introduce a couple
of people that are crucial to bringing
you all of this action we have not only
the commentators but we have our media
specialist woman grand master anastasia
carlovic
[Applause]
and let's not forget about our
journalist for the tournament
international master kostya kavutski
over there
and last
but certainly not least
it's time to introduce the players
we're going to start
with somebody
that didn't let the pandemic slow him
down
this is a player that played tournament
after tournament after tournament
despite difficulties in order to reach
his goals and his dreams a very young
player from new york hans niemann
[Applause]
a personal inspiration since i was a kid
and somebody that's inspired literally
tens of thousands of kids all throughout
latin america the best player to come
out of cuba since jose raulca
[Applause]
a player whose style is absolutely
captivating and every time he starts an
attack well that's the game to switch to
he has been over 2800 and has scored a
victory against every single player here
shakuyar mamidyarov
[Applause]
a player that has seen the top of the
top of the chess world he participated
in the 2018 world chess championship
match against magnus carlson but we
remember him for his performance here at
the sink field cup the best performance
ever with a 7-0 start in 2014.
grand master fabiano caruana
next up the newest addition to the
american team
a player that
dazzles us with his play
manners on the board and off the board
an artist in every way
grand master levon aronian
[Applause]
a player that is no stranger to winning
the grand chess tour he's he has already
done it twice
from minnetonka minnesota
wesley saw
[Applause]
this young man has dazzled us in the
last week he certainly is somebody that
we thought we had to watch out for but
he's already here the winner of the 2022
st louis rapid and blitz alireza furuja
[Applause]
the spotlight was on this player in
dubai as he faced magnus carlsen for the
world championship match and the
spotlight will be back on him as he
tries his luck this time against dingler
in the following championship
his name janne pomnyacci
[Applause]
certainly the man to beat and still the
number one rated player in the world and
reigning world champion
magnus carlson
[Applause]
and to finish this excellent list
the defending champion of the singfield
cup the 2021 winner from france maxime
vascular
[Applause]
next i would like to introduce the
musical directors at the world chess
hall of fame
brian owens and brian woods to the stage
[Applause]
[Music]
hello everyone how are you welcome to st
louis
um
yeah
yeah on behalf of my my creative
colleague brian woods who oversees the
chamber music series we want to just say
how awesome it is to see all of you here
and one of the things that we're so
proud of in this city second only to our
chess
is our music
we have a very rich history uh from this
city i don't know if you've heard of
people like chuck berry or miles davis
uh or michael mcdonald or david sanborn
they're all hacks but they came from
here
and
we are certainly excited about them even
folks like nelly i don't know if you've
heard of him
but one of the great joys now of being
able to oversee this music series and
curate is the ability to create new
works and new music that tell the
narrative and the story of chess which
is a pretty cool story
and uh and for this night and for this
event and this occasion we were honored
with the privilege of creating a work in
honor of bobby fischer
last week as a part of our music series
we debuted the first four movements of
this which were arranged and written by
adam mannis who is a wonderful blessing
to this community and tonight we we held
back the final
piece
of this
uh commission to play for you this
evening so i want to introduce the
players who are on the stage with me and
then we were going to present to you the
final movement of 40 moves honoring
bobby fischer
on piano brian woods
[Applause]
on drums uh we're so proud of this this
son of the city uh he is the drummer for
a little-known jazz guy named gregory
porter
his name is emanuel harold
next to him is another guy who we love
from this city and who's also the bass
player for a little-known jazz singer
named gregory porter
jamal nichols
on guitar tonight this guy is so cool
that he only goes by one name his name
is franco
and joining me as one of the performers
tonight and also one of the
collaborators and contributors to the
work that you're going to hear tonight
he is the director of creative
experience for our new mls soccer team
he is a staple in the city ladies and
gentlemen a pleasure a round of applause
for mastermind
[Applause]
yeah
[Music]
yeah
[Music]
took a pair in the mirror to prepare for
the moment it appears my appearance be
my only opponent had to pile this off
the pieces pushed across the board
started fixing those assistants just so
keeping score shout out prodigy after my
dichotomy study all my moves and they
try to mimic it out of me whole world of
knowledge that i don't think you want as
proud as me
especially because i know just who i'm
about to be
one of the greatest that they've ever
seen did it by myself they need to help
i am the iron team grand master got it
right on grand master all chasing dreams
yet it seemed that i ran faster i see
the world much different than y'all if
you are mounted to one a mountain don't
i know that they found a way to creep
into my head at night searching for my
secrets in a secret such a scary sight
y'all be paranoid about my voice upon
this very mic
but i like curious tick tick tick like a
blood sucking parasite
i'm 20 steps ahead of you king don't let
that energy swing till the day that's
insane
to the day that they see if these
whining so my dreams to the day you get
teams yeah
[Music]
it's
[Music]
oh it's infinity it's infinite see
that's the way we move
[Music]
symphony
[Music]
too many times people don't try their
best
they play the game
but they don't play to win it all
[Music]
but if i'm honest i'm not like the rest
i do it harder play it faster
no one plays it smarter
i don't believe in wasting
careful
time
won't let them see inside my mind
[Music]
take the glory take the faith
cause even
it's all a game
and i'm 40 moves away
[Music]
moves away
[Music]
but it moves away
[Music]
i will save my day
[Music]
40 moves away
[Music]
before that moves away
[Music]
and nobody's gonna take my
glory
[Music]
[Applause]
main hero brown woods
bobby fisher
[Music]
[Music]
do
[Music]
[Music]
well happy national chess day everyone
and thank you for joining us here at
this opening ceremony a reminder the
games start tomorrow at 1pm central join
us at
grandchester.org our broadcast starts at
12 50 and best of luck to the
participants let the best one win thank
you everybody for joining us tonight
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
i'm
i'm showing
[Music]
is all right with me
cause you
make me feel
so brand new
[Music]
i want to spend
[Music]
since we've been together
[Music]